he's primarily known in the United
States among members of my generation as
the Minister of Magic Cornelius fudge
from the Harry Potter movies Robert
Hardy has had a long and varied career
on the stages and screens of England
known for playing Sir Winston Churchill
in five different films he has the
distinction of playing both Churchill
and Franklin D Roosevelt on various
occasions a scholar and respected
authority on the medieval longbow mr.
Hardy has authored two books on the
subject he was one of the experts
consulted with about the longbows found
when the Mary Rose a warship of the
English Tudor Navy of King Henry the
eighth was salvaged during his time at
Madeline College in Oxford he studied
under both CS Lewis and j.r.r tolkien
earning a BA in English with honors in
the BBC adaptation of James Harriet's
all creatures great and small mr. Hardy
played the role of Siegfried Farnham who
was and has probably performed in more
Shakespeare plays than you can name
please join me in welcoming Robert Hardy
back to Hillsdale College
I can't tell you what a joy it is to be
back at Hillsdale I had an absolutely
wonderful week here in October last year
when we were talking about nobody but
Churchill which is why I came and so
tonight I don't really know what to say
at all
because I haven't been commissioned so
I've got so much to say that I don't
know how long you're going to be here
but to mitigate the dangers that are
inherent in not knowing what you're at
I've brought a large timepiece which I
can actually read
I mean it's large enough for me to read
and I won't go on too long I'll see how
many people fall asleep and how the
doors are being used and so on but I've
got various things that I'm absolutely
determined to tell you about I think if
I had any Commission at all from those
in authority about tonight it was that I
was to talk about the theater well I
don't know much about the theater really
because I'm something of an amateur I
went to no acting school as many of my
charming colleagues are too apt to say
but I'm going to start with a word or
two about my ties with your great
country America one of my
great-great-great grandfather's of
course by the time we get to three
grades you've acquired quite a number
having sure because it's doubled up
every time and my particular grandfather
was a man who was born and died in the
little town of Kittery in Maine
and he was in the official documents
which I'm gonna wave about from time to
time because I didn't want to get off
the line he was known in his lifetime as
the hero of Louisbourg because he led an
army which he'd raised himself in Maine
and Massachusetts a number of some let
me tell you 4200 militia sailors and
Marines with 90 ships and vessels which
were provided by what they called the
English who stood off in their
old-fashioned way waiting for action to
happen but he marched up s const himself
on a ridge and was responsible for
taking lui build in 1745 from the French
who were cross about it but nevertheless
say they had to surrender they got it
back on a sort of loan this was during
the War of the Austrian succession which
I'm sure you all know all about a good
deal more than me probably but he was
William Pepperell was of anglo-welsh
descent and had been to Pepperell before
him in Kittery and they were
uninterpreted the same as him William
Pepperell and there'll be another one
who comes in in a moment but this
particular William was a very successful
American dream
ghent I mean as mercantile developer and
as shipbuilder and goodness knows what
all he did do extremely well and he
invested in masses of land of which he
held with his wife vast areas he had a
son who died young and then he was
succeeded by his grandson whose name was
spark spelt Sparhawk also from Kittery
but he had in order to inherit not only
all the land and the wealth but the
title which he'd be a world will William
to succeed her had earned from the King
of England and this grandson became sir
william peveril a baronet and he was the
what's the word something much grander
than there he was the governor of both
Maine and Massachusetts because they
were together at that time and he was of
course running into trouble because
there was that odd occurrence called the
revolution and he was sent packing but
George it was George three by this time
because his grandfather had been dealing
with George - George three was so
touched by his loyalty I mean we call
him in the family we call him the last
loyalist governor of Maine and
Massachusetts I don't think you'd go
with the loyalist adjective but back he
came to England and eventually I
inherited a very beautiful embroidered
waistcoat that he used to wear when he
was living with the king at Windsor
Castle
while until he found somewhere to live
borrowing money I think from anybody in
sight because he had nothing left from
America and I nearly brought it because
I thought you'd be intrigued to see it
but then my courage deserted me and I
thought if my suitcase gets torn open or
ruined in the journey or unpacking or
something it would be too sad to lose
this heirloom so I'm afraid I have no
Westfield except for this other boring
great number but it surely is very
brutal and in very good order and I'm
very proud and happy to have it not
quite enough about him other American
links that I have is that I played yes
years ago I played Hamlet by William
Shakespeare and Henry the fifth by
William Shakespeare on alternate nights
right through the summer festival at
Ravinia outside Chicago and had a most
ravishing time which brings me to some
of my other links because I was put to
stay with the most wonderful family Jim
Douglas James Douglas who was
Eisenhower's minister for air and they
were a wonderful wonderful generous kind
lot and this is every time I come to
America I I am astonished I'm a cease
being astonished but it Hills there when
I came in October last to talk about
Churchill I was absolutely staggered by
the courtesy by the elegant manners and
the tolerance of an invading Englishman
that I met it was enchanting and I'm
finding the same again although of
course it not being a thing dedicated to
any particular I mean you're all far too
busy learning the most that Hillsdale
can teach you which I should think is a
very good deal and more than probably
and
else that I've ever been or heard of
although I was very lucky at Oxford to
be as you were told to be tutored by CS
Lewis I don't know whether to name means
anything to you but he was a most lovely
man much thinking Hillsdale it does mean
you go deal to you and junior are
talking which I know mean something to
you
who taught anglo-saxon I'll means we get
on a cruise and thready
both of our you booger Ottawa do driver
he'll Rudy taught me eternity knee meet
his faith a Oldman man off stock meet
him that's how he taught me quite
believably to speak anglo-saxon and of
course he also taught us all who came to
him how to do Chaucer dude do Chaucer
any of you it's it's a lovely sound I
think a little bit of French little bit
of English a little bit of this certain
the other one not Aprilia with his sure
assault the draweth of match hath ter
said to the rota and every Bernard ride
I then long and folk to go on pilgrimage
from every shear of England to
Canterbury I went the holy blissful
martyr for two sake who have him have
happened when that they were ways well
obviously I'm right I do tend to forget
we had lately last week indeed your
great Obama over he came to congratulate
the Queen on being 90 he forgot to
congratulate me on being six months
older than the Queen
but I forgave him and he was very urbane
and charming and told us all that the
most important thing to America and to
him was the special relationship and I
don't know whether anybody told you I
entitled this chat to you as two lives
and two ships but actually there's a
third ship the International Fellowship
between your great country and mine long
way at last
but they soon as that charm had gone
past his lips he started lecturing us on
what we were to do about Europe and
which way were to vote in the referendum
but so he got whacked a bit for that in
the English press and then I suppose
there's one other that I met there a
wonderful family who's who were derived
from a general I think in the civil war
your civil war Penniman the Penniman
family and I'd hoped that they might
reach up here better didn't think
they've been able to because I became
really really close friends of theirs
and have remained so so there's another
link and I says the last link that's
worth mentioning is that when I was
filming Churchill parts of the
wilderness years and we were spending a
week or two in Monument Valley standing
in for instead of going to Hollywood
which Churchill did visit several times
and met everybody there but we decided
Monument Valley would be more fun and we
met Indians and all sorts there and I
had a pair of another pair I had a false
tooth plate which I'd had made up on the
advice of a dentist who was taught by
Churchill's own dentist because I wanted
something like Churchill
had to to fight against instead of his
very thicknesses which he had to
overcome you know he was told when he
was young and his parents sent him to an
expert in straight speaking the man
spent several days I think trying to get
him to speak straight love an ordinary
human and failed completely and said no
no no you'll you'll be all right you'll
do Persky well just a warning don't
engage in anything which includes public
speaking you weren't really oh but he
did but these teeth were I'm not sure it
was a good idea because it made it
really very hard to do some of the time
and when we were in Monument Valley we
were be given lunch you know from the
commissary and I had to take for eating
I could take these things out and put
him on the side and I put him on the
side of a table and a wild dog every
time you know you know he wasn't gonna
be TAS but he did eat my teeth and went
off with them and that was the last I
saw them so I had to invent the psalm
that had been induced by this cleverly
conceived
can she conceived plate myself I had to
do it without help
now the next thing I suppose you know
there was for some years in Monument
Valley well I don't know I never met him
again because I was very close with him
the next thing that I simply must talk
about because I was told I was too is
about acting I don't know how many of
you if any of you are concerned with the
acting fraternity here which I believe
is wonderful but acting is an
extraordinary pastime and when asked by
people that come up to the Eldar
they like me and they say what do we do
to be said we want to be an actor we
want to be an actress my answer is
always don't pray think of something
sensible but I will tell you what I
think about acting in short order I keep
looking at my watch
anybody asleep you're very kind-hearted
you see that's what I call good manners
I think it's absolutely wonderful
if you are determined to become actors
my saying don't will not have the least
effect upon you because one of the
things you've got to have is total
determination you have also to be in my
opinion slightly what we call in England
round the bend off the trolley mad there
should be a touch of madness in you
you've got somebody vying to be
president at the moment who I think has
the right sort of attitude but what else
do you need you need obviously you need
talent and talent is what does so much
harm but if I may say so your stage when
you are doing wonderfully at a place
like Hillsdale or Oxford or Cambridge or
Harvard or whatever I must just say in
brackets that I'm so impressed with what
Hillsdale College offers but I rather
wish I'd come here or not being a doctor
but then I would have missed those two
Stalin people who did teach me the other
things you need are a spine of steel and
enormous undaunted
patience which you will really need
because it's not an easy profession it
was very easy when I joined because I
joined it having served King as we say
and indeed that's one other thing that
always reminds me of America's
remembering that I was taught to fly for
the Royal Air Force England Britain in
Texas which was heaven because they had
buttermilk sugar everything that we
hadn't had for quite a long time and
wonderful people I met there too
I miss the man who called himself the
dispatcher who really he used to call
our airplanes ships and you say honey
your ship for well there don't let it
frighten you and then one day I'd leaked
out that he was up all night farming and
I was so lost in admiration at this
kindly gentle man who said that don't be
afraid he then went home in the evening
and started working on his farm which he
did as far as I can make out for most of
the night the few men I totally admired
to give me I'm told that Hillsdale is
one of the worst places for that
particular kind of course it's her in
the spring particularly but yeah
patience you will need patience it was
so easy when I joined the forces of
acting because there was of course sadly
an enormous trough a great trench of
those who never came back none of those
who came back and were unable to follow
what they wanted to follow and those who
simply had changed their mind so they
were on the lookout and this is one of
the things that I'd guessed which is why
I went back to my
University but I'd already been thinking
that would be this enormous gap to be
filled with younger people and it said
it worked out so that I took my finals
that some of you were going to do this
coming weekend Donnie and for which I
wish you every sort of luck my my heart
will be with you awful time good
exciting exciting too and a chance to
look ahead at what's coming and I was
able having done my finals in November
of whatever year it was that I was able
to start rehearsing at Stratford
Shakespeare Stratford on Avon in January
of the following year and that is easy
because it doesn't often happen like
that
there are dangers other dangers too in
following the acting trade one of which
is of course you are your only equipment
and it does make you terribly
self-centered quite rightly but somehow
you have to correct that
gently work on not being totally
self-centered and try and make the
center of your focus the next part
you're going to play that for me has
always been the exciting thing that's
why I'm that kind of course there are
two at least two but two main kinds of
actor one is the actor who is always
himself
I mean it's jolly nice for us all who
watch him or her because we can always
say oh yeah they are doing it exactly
the same in a quite different part and
there are those of us who try to get
behind the character we play that's why
I've always loved
being offered parts of people who really
have lived because there is a body of
evidence to dig about to find out about
to try and get yourself in sympathy with
to understand and to try and become
which is what I tried to do with Winston
Churchill for ages and ages whether I
have succeeded or not I don't know
probably not but I've seen the result of
some of my efforts and just occasion it
was a glimmer of what he was this
extraordinary man by the way I suppose
you all know that your president here
dr. Arnn has written the best book about
Winston Churchill called Churchill's
trial if you haven't got it I beg you to
get it I've had in my library up until
October last and well over a hundred
books by various people some good some
medium some not good on Winston
Churchill I mean people never stopped
writing about him and quite the best the
most understanding the most truly
philosophical understanding of Churchill
the character is by your president dr.
Arnn who first invited me to here come
here in in October I beg you to read it
it is an absolute work of art and a work
of complete understanding it's a joy
I've read it twice and I can't wait to
get back home and start it again and try
and read it from a different perspective
so back to this danger of being your
only equipment as an actor and therefore
concentrating on yourself you have some
how to adjust the mechanics of that
situation yourself very few people are
going to help you there are
people who can help some directors are
very good at it some people in other
branches of theater or filmmaking and
that's why I became an actor because of
film because I was of that generation
who had the whole upbringing in acting
from film there different sort of film
in those days from what we watch now I
watched on the plane the revenant
have you seen it it's a shaker isn't it
and the plane started shaking it was so
frightened I thought it was wonderful
and they were trying to serve dinner at
the same time so I missed a whole bit in
the middle
I thought never mind I'll see it on the
big screen it'll be great and then after
about five minutes thinking I thought I
don't think I can face this film on a
big screen
all that's bear mauling and stuff and
curls here god it's an extraordinary fan
brilliantly made brilliantly lit
brilliantly acting but I'm not sure I
could face it again so you'll have to
try and get over that employment and
focus upon yourself because like
everybody else in the world you won't in
fact be the most important person except
for that extraordinary moment when you
stride out onto the stage and you become
somebody else and there so one of that
other kind of actor but we all recognize
I'm saying thank goodness we know who he
or she is such a relief but you will
overcome it because then you can enjoy
yourselves and enjoy the business if
you're my kind of act of trying to get
inside somebody then you can really
enjoy all that part of it the research
it's the research when I was paying
Churchill's the last time in an 8-hour
epic we have we broke for a fortnight
over Christmas and my director wonderful
man
last night dad said to me don't you dare
lose Winston over the holiday and my
family kept to have said terrified of
losing what I'm what little I'd have Eve
Dov Winston but my family complain
raucous - ever the whole Christmas
period oh hey why did you have to bring
that ghastly man into the house Oh
heaven sake stop so I did stop I just
engineered stopping and did stop and
when we went back to film at Chartwell
the Churchill house where we'd been for
weeks destroying the place the director
said cut cut cut
let's go for a walk and he said to me
what's happened to mr. Churchill over
Christmas and I said oh dear have I lost
him well quite a lot yes you better have
a thing take half an hour off and I had
to think my way back in to this kind of
Churchill which I did which was an
effort to not copy but evoke him and he
kept saying to me I'm going to make a
short assembly a sort of our assembly
when we got enough stuff and you ought
to come and see it and I said no I never
will
no I know no I know one but eventually
he said right you're coming tonight
caught me unawares and I said no I can't
I really can't see myself I'll just lose
all confidence that I have he said you
are to come I beg you to come and I
order you to come and I said will you
give me a bottle of whiskey now
and he said course I'll give you three
so armed with two bottles of whiskey I
sat through it and I realized that what
I thought I got right which was his
voice
I hadn't what I had got quite right with
some of the physical aspects but what I
was eventually relieved about was that I
had not copied him so much as found a
way to evoke him which brought him into
people's minds so that people watching
actually began after a bit to think they
were watching him and that gradually
came back to me when the whole eight
hours was complete and down and pleased
me very greatly so I think that's
probably enough about acting isn't it
except I'll tell you that when I was and
all of us of my age who were filling
this tragic valley of the Dead
we were dominated by three great actors
of our period our previous two-hour
period
Laurence Olivier you may have heard of
John Gielgud who you may not have heard
of Ralph Richardson I think the greatest
of the three you might have heard of and
we spent our time some consciously some
unconsciously imitating them in turn I
was best at Ralph Richardson because I
thought he was the best I thought him
the best actor of all ever
and at a time when I was really quite
famous he has in years ago I saw him
across the room as a reception in London
and I went and knelt at his feet and
said sir Ralph I've always been total
admirer of yours I think you're the
greatest actor Britain has ever produced
and he said oh how very kind and I was
really quite famous at this time
he said that's kind I'm glad you said
that and who are you put me in my place
I think probably I'm going to the last
injunction that I have about being an
actor or an actress and that is find
something else to accompany your life as
an actor there will be gaps there will
be terrible heart-rending times when
nobody rings you up when nobody says oh
I've been admiring you for years I want
you so much in my next film or he has a
wonderful play will you join me there
will be bad times and that's when you
need the patience which I underlined a
moment ago and you must choose what you
want to be your alternative life I was
spoiled I was just so lucky because at
the age of five or six I found in my
father's attic I wondered about a good
deal I found two long bows you know what
they are sure you do and I took them
gingerly dancers to the grown-ups to say
what are these and why and I suppose it
was my father who said oh yes I remember
those there's a eighteenth-century
family longbows I wouldn't try and do
anything with them they're dry as dust
because they've been in hot attics so by
the time I was eight I had broken both
of them but it had engendered an
extraordinary sort of fascination this
simple rather exquisite curve and I
began to want to study the history of
the longbow which I did and still do I'm
guilty of two major books one I've
brought a copy of one of the last copies
because they're both had a print as a
present for dr. arm in return for his
present to me in October and the other
one which I'd love to have brought and
put in the Hillsdale library which I did
with a proper professor of medieval
history it's called the Great War burn
it's the whole history of the longbow in
use in war in armies from it's very
beginning right through the year of
Hastings when poor Harold of England if
you remember was hit in the eye and lost
the Battle of Hastings to William the
bastard of Normandy but it's a hugely
heavy thick book and I think wouldn't
have got onto the airplane without
danger so I'm gonna tell anybody who
wants nobody what it's called and where
you may be able to buy a very expensive
copy of it but that's that's the result
of years and years of study and the
study started at a symposium rather like
the Churchill symposium here at
Hillsdale last October but at a
university called reading in England
where I came across two people again who
I had been working with on the physical
development of the longbow through the
ages and there they won curiously enough
to get many people there and that tenna
the feel of the conference was that our
ancestors who preceded us really were
thick as two bricks dragged their
knuckles on the ground and knew nothing
about anything and these two professors
from the Imperial College of Science and
I who had been working together were the
only three who stood up and said you are
talking nonsense
we have forgotten so much of what they
knew and what they learned that we
should be ashamed of ourselves and we
talked separately on that line of
questioning so we went back rejuvenated
to our work on history of military
archery which was our subject and what
was the strength of these bows
how were they handled how were they
deployed and came up with all sorts of
interesting facts and the further we got
into the subject the more we couldn't
believe what we were discovering I don't
know whether any of you are archers but
the average weight of a bow nowadays
modern or ancient longbow or modern
engineered brilliantly engineered modern
bows that have their place in the
Olympics for instance the average draw
weight that you have to hold at the top
is about 60 maybe one or two of 70
pounds draw away you've gotta hold it
enough to take the measure of the target
and then let go as quick as you can but
we were coming up with figures which
made nonsense of that we were coming up
with figures which absolutely staggered
us and we thought now we somewhere we've
made a mistake we were coming up with
figures between a hundred and a hundred
and seventy plus pounds joy imagine
trying to hold for a long enough moment
to aim a hundred and seventy pounds
thank God you use plans and answers as
we do whenever I write about it nearer
Europe it has to be translated into
meters and all those things you know
which I've never understood
but we thought now what can we do this
is really defeating we don't believe
what we're discovering so we leaked some
of our figures surreptitiously
and the entire world of archery rose up
as a man or a woman and said these these
geeks are lying to us they're talking
absolute rubbish so there was a great
surge of hostility and luckily we knew a
professor in Amsterdam who was a great
authority in physics and he said he knew
these two professors who I was working
with he said send me the vital
statistics of bows and I will tell you
by return of post but it pretty nearly
what the bows actually weighed in their
heyday when there were babes and so we
did and he came back with these
extraordinary eye figures which had so
defeated us so we had some bows made
already which I'd ordered to be what I
called approximation approximations they
were sort of copies of the Mary Rose
bows now I'm stopped you briefly take a
brief pause here because I must talk to
you about two ships one of them is yours
or rather belongs to France but it's in
Texas do you know about it they've had
about thing here I have to turn up
documents because of my sad age LaBella
in 1684 king new xiv of france sent
explorer Renny Hobart Sevigny De La
Salle across the ocean with four ships
and four hundred peoples in North
America
the Explorer was to land at the mouth of
mice in Mississippi River established a
colony and trade routes here we go again
same thing always now isn't it which is
one of the things that Obama said to us
by the way he said if you stay in Europe
you'll be okay
if you come out of the Europe is this
awful word brexit I hate it
he said if you employ brexit you'll be
at the back of the line back of the
queue he honored us by saying Q instead
of line but he told us that we would be
at the back if we came out and that we
did take exception to that
anyhow the plan was never realized by
this ship and his the French captain
instead in a series of remarkable
circumstances
La Salle lost ships to pirates and
disasters of various kind sail past his
destination destination and was murdered
by his own men he was sort of unlucky I
was near in 1686 labelled the one
remaining expedition ship wrecked in a
storm sank to the muddy bottom bottom of
that Agathe bed you know where that is
where anyway where it rested undisturbed
for over 300 years
in 1996 archeologists located that ship
in the process of excavating covering
and conserving what was left of the hull
along with well more than 1.6 million
artifacts and the La Bella and her
contents now the center of attraction at
the Texas artifacts Museum they tell the
whole story of the French sailors and
colonists everything else and make sure
to see the brass cannon with lifting
handles shaped like dolphins well I have
passed that message
and it's the center of the Texas Museum
exhibition so you must go and see that
whether you like it or not but at the
same time
no not same time earlier 15:45 a ship an
English ship of war who was the admiral
of Henry the eighth's Navy whose father
Henry the seventh had commissioned it
and it was laid down in 1508 or nine and
first took to the sea the following year
and sank in action against the French
who else not against you just off the
south coast of England and eventually
the wreck was discovered and a whole
enterprise was set in motion by the most
extraordinary woman who ran the whole
affair called Margaret rule I don't know
whether you read anything about her but
she was the the soul spirit of thee of
the raising of the ship which eventually
came up in 1982 and in 1982 no 90
earlier 1977 her desk at the
headquarters of the enterprise was
covered with books about technical books
about every sort of study she would have
to go into Tudor shipbuilding Tudor
rigging everything everything piles of
books and among the piles was my first
book called long though surprisingly and
she said I really mean I've got a book
when up from the depths came
what the diver came into her office and
showed her and said ah I think it's a
pikestaff and she looked at it for a
second and said no it isn't that's our
first longbow now wait a minute I've got
a book she unearthed mine from low down
in the pile and said this fellow who is
he Hardy we've got to get hold of him
I've dipped into this book it's very
good very knowledgeable we've got to get
him so I was got and eventually I was
commissioned to take charge of the bows
as they came up because they came up
thick and fast that first rows just
short of seven foot and very nobly and
covered with sea creatures you know
nasty little creatures who deeton into
it but gradually more and more bows that
looked as if they'd been made just the
other day came up in boxes and I was put
in charge of the whole lot 138 complete
and masses of bits and pieces all of
which were useful and I was commissioned
to look after them deal with them bring
him back to life and test them as far as
was possible to the point of if
necessary destroying up to three in fact
we only destroyed one and slightly
damaged two others which I was able to
repair but that was that was my
alternative life and by god it was hard
work it took years and years but well
worth it I could stop acting all
together for a year certainly and forget
about all the difficulties of that kind
of life and its rewards and deal with
the history of the longbow which I then
started of course to to write about my
studies furthering where I'd started but
the the ship herself when she came up
was on a day after the day that had been
arranged for her to come up and I'd been
down there like the Prince of Wales he
was down there and a host of other
people thousands upon thousands in
little boat watching for this mulch to
surface and be restored to the world and
it was cancelled for the Sunday it was
supposedly the day of the raising and
put off to the Monday and I thought I
really must do some rehearsing on this
film that I'm in where I'd been called
to do racing so I dutifully went to
London and rehearsed and was having
breakfast in the canteen when a fellow
who knew me burst in and said aren't you
something to do with the mary-rose and I
said yes confess he said they've just
dropped her I said yeah god what what
what do you mean rushed for a phone
luckily got straight through to the PR
people who said ceased to panic we
haven't dropped her she just slid in her
holding harness a tiny bit but nothing
has been broken come on dance quick as
you can
so I abandon rehearsal and went on down
then actually saw her beginning to come
in I saw her fully surfaced and begin
her journey back to Portsmouth where she
was built in 1508 and nine
extraordinaire she was then birthed
about 50 yards from the birth where she
was actually constructed It was as if
she had to get back home but now where
should I gather from the
I've got endless notes you see to guide
me but I seem unwilling to be guided I
think one of the things to return to why
I became an actor
it was never objected to in the family
but I think they did whisper behind
closed doors just leave him alone he'll
forget all about it but I didn't of
course and I think one of the things
that finally cemented it aged five
possibly six was a family wedding and I
was supposed to hold one side of the
very end of a very long chair and train
of my aunt who was being married and
that the other side was a girl of the
same sort of age who rejoiced in the
name of Teresa Cullen rogers Clubman say
you can tell that it was quite a society
wedding and she she had a nerve fit
before we went into the church and
refused to do anything so my grandfather
emerged from the church when he was
going to give his daughter away and said
hold out your arm so I hold up my arms
we'll talk about that and he said if
you're careful and avoid the great sag
in the middle hold it really far out and
look down at the where your feet are
going I think you can do it alone so I
did it alone and up the aisle we went
and every I in a very full church was
turned first on the bride and bridegroom
I have to say and then on me during my
solo act
and I thought this is what I master this
is whatever is worth having everyone's
attention so for the very word
reason that cemented my determination
the worst reason because that's not the
best reason for becoming an actor
because you want to be the center of
attention all the time but that did
cement things a bit now that time is
getting on and you might have some
questions so I think the best thing for
me to do is to stop right there and say
do you want to say anything back to me
like that was the most boring speech
ever or well tried well failed or
anything else you'd like me to touch
upon do please speak up yeah
by talking I was taught to shorter time
only the time when I was waiting to go
and be taught by the air force so it was
about nine months and he he was a
miraculous teacher and after the very
first tutorial with six of us he was a
university tutor say he we were six to
one against him whereas in my college
with Luis we will either one one-on-one
or sometimes two on one with him so he
could take as long as we liked but after
the first tutorial was talking at his
college
he said now next week Thursday we're
going to the burden baby and we all
looked inquiring me and he said oh come
on
that's the Oxford for the eagle and
child it's a pub I will set you all up a
pint of the best beer
and we will arrange ourselves as I
dictate when we get there when we got
there he put himself with his back to
the window table between us and him and
us six reigns to round him and then he
covered his head face and said I'm not
going to look at you again until the end
of the game and when we get there I've
got a game to play with you but for the
moment I promise not to look at you all
change your places and I will just say
when you're set tell me when you're
ready I will call one two three four
five six and I want each of you to speak
for at least two minutes and don't be
for God's sakes shy that would bore me
to extinction
okay right I'm not seeing you don't
believe me
number one speak for two minutes and we
each of us spoke some timidly some out
right and when he came to me I forget
which number I was he said interesting
interesting very mixed he'd already
analyzed two or three people where they
came from what were the influences on
their speech and they confessed each of
them at the end of his analysis he was
absolutely on the money with them came
to me and he said this is interesting
it's complicated there's a certain sort
of world she lived in your voice but
unfortunately it covered over with a
rather posh London sort of grandeur and
then he went on and he said am i right
at all and I said yes I was born and
brought up on the Welsh border with a
leg in England and a leg in Montgomery
sure and as to London yes I know it
pretty well and passed Sandford
true and he then went off and finished
it all and finished the others and said
now I'll explain why I wanted us to play
this little game because when I say to
you that this is what Anglo Saxon
sounded like and I gave you a bit
earlier on and this is what Chaucer
should sound like gave you a bit I want
you to believe me because believe you me
I have studied this matter for the whole
of my life and I am totally and utterly
correct and we did believe him and we
believed him forever afterwards so that
was the game and that was particularly a
tolkien-esque sort of thing to do and we
had great fun with him anybody else
wants to say anything
yes and yes and yes and unfortunately it
started early on and he was the greatest
director I came across ever and he gave
his name to run Guthrie to the Guthrie
Theater up north of here a bit and
because he was so good and so
encouraging and so utter delightful and
so inventive
in every possible way that every other
director I came across afterwards fell
sort of him so if these other directors
fell sort of anything in my estimation
they got the rough end of my tongue
which wasn't a good thing but he was
great and of course other directors who
I've worked for I've really enjoyed the
one who did the eight-month classic on
Churchill he I loved and my godson was
sitting there who also played with some
of you last evening played acting games
he acted with me in a film about the man
who broke all the records on the salt
flats at Utah sir Malcolm Campbell I'm
sorry to say was English and he played
the son who brought broke all the water
speed records and finally was killed on
an English lake because he went so fast
the boat came back on itself you may
have seen film of that
the actual happening it's heartbreaking
to see but we played father and son and
my favorite scene in that but from all
of it was fun was when father had just
got older his school report which was
really quite bad and he called the boy
in to dress him down and we had a very
good scene together about you the
awfulness of school reports any other
thoughts because it is now short by five
minutes of an hour which is quite enough
for you it's certainly enough for me
liking Shakespeare's the best thing in
the world I love it absolutely love it
part renting else it's so easy to learn
the lines they're large and stick with
you although I know tutorial that I was
in this morning and watched brilliant
brilliant tutorial what's his name Paul
ray Paul ray and he was doing a tutorial
on my three favorite plays Henry for 184
205 which you're a wonderful Triple E
making nificent three plays he was quite
brilliant and he asked me he said at one
point do you know the speech in which of
the second by John of Gaunt about
England I said of course I do
every Englishman knows it would you
please give it he said and I started off
I got through two lines and stopped
absolutely bang dried completely
so I don't remember everything on
account of age you understand it is true
playing Shakespeare is magic cause the
actors answer to what's the play you
awful is that you've played that you
enjoyed mostly actors answers you've
been lucky enough to play it is very
often Hamlet
it's one of the greatest players ever
written anywhere and it's certainly my
favorite but very close to it comes
Coriolanus because redoubtable father
bad character I always felt I understood
so he comes quite close but there's four
players Richard Henry Henry Henry are my
best and that's what now I played Hamlet
and 5th at the Ravinia fest fiddle
festival by Chicago there and
unfortunately the theater which is very
beautiful is open there they opened the
sides and just below the theatre runs an
enormous Lee busy railroad so when it
came to the end there of Hamlet when
poor Hamlet is dying and should be
allowed to say the rest is silence
but an enormous chain used to come on
night by night so sometimes I used to
have to say the rest and just hold it
until the chain came and went because it
was a stop though there was a getting
off point of the Train and after
everybody had forgotten which play they
were watching
I would say the rest his silence and
sometimes he got a hollow a laugh
sometimes it didn't those are the nights
that I enjoyed because it meant that all
that had gone before three hours before
had worked for them
I didn't air almost any play of
Shakespeare's is so worth doing not all
of them I do confess I hate Love's
Labour's Lost chiefly I think because
the designer had made us all were very
stiff roughs which dug into our Lexus
very famous designer - I could have
killed him that's an hour folks so you
have every excuse to leave by the
quickest door but on the other hand if
there's anything else you want to say
pray say
well CC is this thing I've ever done it
required no acting at all and just had
to learn the lines
oh it's if in doubt were written up for
you and Harold's like that and it was
packed full of actors and actresses I'd
known for years and years and years and
we all behaved quite badly so one
director or other used to come roaring
Ron from the scene of action real film
action and say for goodness sake shut up
and we used to shut up a bit but it was
great fun and the kids were so good
really good sensible kids being superbly
educated with first class tutors the
whole time
the moment a director shouted cut off
their toddle to a tutorial and very
bright boys they became didn't it it was
fun but not demanding at all
I've when I started doing it I thought
this is it I've retired my first
director I'm the first one that I came
in on Harry Potter - I guess it was was
directed by lovely American called post
the name of the great Explorer what
speak up
Chris Columbus that's right yeah he said
by the way yeah you could my place
please play the minister for magic by
the way my name's Christopher Columbus
and I said I don't believe it
he said just call me Chris he was a nice
man and the best of all the directors we
had was a Brazilian was he a Brazilian
yeah he was wonderful and we were
filming in Scotland in August which is
anybody who knows Scotland knows he's
asking for disaster and it rained and
rained and rained and three of us were
all staying in the same hotel three of
the leads used to be put into three
separate black Mercedes because we
weren't legally allowed to travel
together for safety's sake insurance and
all that we used to arrive at this
Highland location soaking wet and there
he was trudging up and down the mountain
hardly for the mist and fog able to see
us and he used to say things like I
can't see you my camera can't see you
especially you get back in your nice
cars go back to your hotel and have a
really good long show please do
I'm reaching away looking like a funeral
possession and have a usually a very
good lunch but were on call self idle
clock by which time we were incapable of
even simple demands of Harry Potter
oh that is lovely I love that I love
being of that I couldn't believe my luck
because I'm a countryman the country
bumpkin you know live my life with
animals and I was asked to do it again
for real in front of the cameras it was
sometimes quite difficult because the
crews with the big lamps and cameras and
all this and that I would walk past a
line of thoroughbreds behind them asking
to be kicked and I the countrymen used
to go up and say for goodness sake don't
do that again
you're one of you will get killed and
Christopher Timothy who you remember
played the young vet I had some
screaming and yelling from a loose box
on a farm and he was alone in there with
a thoroughbred together with the
thoroughbreds breeder and owner who had
been asked to live in the thoroughbred
up a bit so that Christopher's character
would be in danger and by god he was in
danger
because I ran down to where it was and
saw Christopher's scalp just his party's
hair parting a hoof behind hoof of this
celebrator by now is really not enjoying
the game parting his hair and I went
straight to the writer I said to
Christopher come out of there and I went
straight to the rector and said you mad
you've nearly killed your leading actor
which was true and then he said I don't
why your turns coming you're gonna have
to you're gonna have to be run away with
by the same horse and I said no I'm not
because I knew enough about horses to no
one fall can ruin you for a month maybe
six months maybe if allies life and
anyway he I refused so I knew enough
about horses - no it was perfect idiocy
so I didn't do it but no stunt man did
it very nasty turn he was dragged across
a whole cobble yard quite bad I was
dragged by cattle but people were
astonished when quite happily I stripped
my sleeve or pulled my shirt off and put
my hand right up the back end of a cow
or a calf or dealt with lambs being born
and I remember a moment when we've been
working all night at pulling lambs out
and the joke was that Siegfried was in a
dinner jacket
with a white stiff shirt and it emerged
cavalry covered in blood
ha ha ha very funny and we came out into
the dawn light and there was some
newspaper people and one of them came up
to me and said mr. Hardy I gather you've
just delivered a lamb I said lamb I
think I've done 15
and he said Oh have you well there and
was that the first lamb you ever
delivered and I said no he said whenever
you are delivered lambs and I said at
home he said have you really did you do
you mean you actually done it
and I said yes how old were you and I
said honestly I can't remember
five six something like that he did he
didn't believe me but he got in the
purpose but it was fun and all the
horses which is my particular joy the
horse and secret of course was um was an
f1 vet so I was rightly placed but there
were some good horses and good breeders
with us uh warning us about this one or
that one you know but we we did okay and
it was fun it was very very hard work
and we worked through two of the worst
winters that they ever had in that part
of Yorkshire but survived I mean at
times we had to stop filming because we
couldn't actually speak our mouths were
frozen but it was so it was worth doing
I think it went on too long and I kept
saying sir and the more they said that
the more they said stay please well
chess Moses was good
and then it was started being shown in
America of course and I was very well
received thank goodness this is a little
particular cough medicine for Hillsdale
okay oh thank you thank you